autre région a vécu ces dernières années
plusieurs épisodes de sécheresse très
important les études le disent nous
aurons dans une trentaine d'années le
climat de la côte d'azur et dans au
siècle prochain celui de la grèce ce
qu'on voudrait savoir c'est comment les
uns les autres vous si vous arrivez à la
présidence du conseil régional vous
entendez adapter notre région au
réchauffement climatique julien odoul
vous avez la parole
l'environnement déjà c'est notre
quotidien à tous c'est évidemment notre
cadre de vie
c'est notre économie puisque c'est les
factures que nous payons c'est notre
électricité
c'est la biodiversité c'est tout ça
c'est pas de l'idéologie
moi je suis pour une écologie heureuse
une écologie positive pas une écologie
est la triste robe c'est à dire
notamment une écologie qui veut taxer
encore plus avec cette écotaxe qui est
une aberration qui ne fera pas chuter la
pollution mais en tout cas qui fera
chuter le nombre d'emplois dans notre
région
et moi je suis pour une écologie aussi
qui est pragmatique qui est lucide c'est
à dire pas le déploiement massif des
halls yen qui est la marotte et
malheureusement l'obsession de la
candidate sortante 403 éoliennes qui
infestent nos terroirs en bourgogne
franche-comté marie-guite dufay veut
continuer dans cette obsession qui
encore une fois saccagent la
biodiversité pour plombe l'attractivité
économique puisque évidemment on veut
bien aller à vézelay
on veut bien aller arc-et-senans on veut
bien aller voir le magnifique patrimoine
des châteaux mais on n'a pas envie de
voir des éoliennes
donc moi ce que je souhaite c'est déjà
posé la question bourguignon aux francs
comtois un grand référendum sur la
politique environnementale et ensuite
clairement moratoire sur l'implantation
d'éoliennes projet de démantèlement qui
sont tout à fait possibles avec des
recours et je soutiendrai toutes les
associations de défense de la nature
pardon vous allez faire pour les
démonter vous avez pas le droit
bien sûr qu'on peut avec des recours
vous savez que ça existe dans d'autres
départements les collectivités qui
soutiennent des associations qui
soutiennent des associations rigole
julien auditeurs se tramait ce qu'elle
sait a su hallucinant c'est qu'en fait
on ne regarde pas ce qui se passe en
dehors des frontières la bourgogne
franche comté
vous avez des associations qui ont été
soutenues qui ont permis notamment de
démonter certaines éoliennes que ce soit
pour des nuisances sanitaires pour des
nuisances sonores des nuisances
environnementales donc c'est tout à fait
possible
encore une fois c'est une question de
volonté et ensuite l'investissement sur
les énergies
réellement renouvelables c'est à dire
que nous avons l'hydroélectricité nous
avons l'hydrogène nous avons la filière
bois tout cela c'est évidemment vertueux
possible et c'est de l'emploi encore
pour noter les jeunes iturrioz sur les
éoliennes c'est dément le rassemblement
national avec qui j'avais pas encore eu
l'honneur de départ puisque pas vu
monsieur no 12 dans les cinq débats
précédents fait beaucoup de vent moi je
parlerais voulait qu'on parle des olé
mêlée je suis désolé l'environnement la
transition écologique la transition
énergétique c'est pas que les éoliennes
et donc moi je ne souhaite pas réduire
le débat ce tag à la biodiversité diallo
je souhaite en faire une grande cause
régionale parce que l'eau de l'hiver ça
doit être clos de l'été et mettre en
harmonie les dispositifs législatifs
pour la rétention d'eau notamment pour
les maraîchers des agriculteurs etc
pensez que c'est un enjeu fort
évidemment accompagné le logement dans
la transition énergétique sont les
intercommunalités qui le font
principalement mais la région doit être
là dessus aussi
on veut tous un mix énergétique vous
savez être tous contre quelque chose où
tout pour quelque chose ça n'a plus de
sens aujourd'hui l'éolien
je pense qu'il ne faut pas le mettre à
la porte si je puis dire d'abord il faut
rappeler je rappelle à monsieur d'où le
cas du mal à avoir révisé que ça relève
de l'état c'est l'état qui décide c'est
pas les présidents de région par contre
la région qui finance les honduriens
c'est la région de lazio en voilà voilà
phase i est bien là mais les gens n'en
veulent pas curien suffisamment la
région qui est suffisamment monsieur
d'affilée à respecter l'autre si vous
êtes président de région ça serait
peut-être bien vous appreniez sattouf
dont la jolie future ue forme de vendée
voilà c'est bon m'autorise à parler à
l'essai du coup je voulais dire que il
ya par exemple des zones où ça ne gène
pas en bordure d'autoroute où il faut
pas que ça dit fier aux paysannes il
faut pas que ça gêne des habitants mais
ça fait partie de sa vie de nos ancêtres
utiliser le vent depuis très longtemps
pour l'énergie
tu le paies trêve n'est pas d'accord non
pas du tout enfin je suis pas d'accord
avec ce que je viens d'entendre je suis
enfin on est on le référendum sur
l'éolien il est déjà fait je vous
renvoie à l'étude que vient de sortir
opinionway pour la bourgogne et franche
comté
vous avez 70 à 80% des habitants qui se
prononce contre l'éolien c'est fini
c'est fini l'éolien et donc elle nous
fait à la plaine où on a gardé les
centrales carrément mari monsieur
chevreuil on a fait alliance
oui avec le mouvement écologiste
indépendant qui est un mouvement
d'antoine waechter anti-éoliens pro
nucléaire
et volontiers chasseurs donc je vais
vous dire clairement on a une on a une
énergie quelle énergie l'atpu décarbonés
qu'ils soient qui s'appelle le nucléaire
on la soutient
donc on construit des centrales ont
franchement on n'a pas besoin mais on
est en autonomie pourquoi voulez-vous de
nouvelles centrales
il suffit d'entretenir les centrales qui
existent en france qui arrive en fin de
vie mais l'an dernier mais on l'aimé on
les entretient tout simplement
mais on se pose des problèmes heures
qu'on en a pas vous savez que l'énergie
éolienne qui produit par les éoliennes
ont l'ex porte aujourd'hui elle est en
plus de notre propre production
nationale donc on arrête de fantasmer
autour de l'éolien c'est une mauvaise
énergie
elle porte atteinte à la biodiversité
elle détruit le paysage et le paysage
c'est d'abord le sens même de notre
environnement
donc oui aux énergies décarbonées type
la méthanisation résonner la petite
hydroélectricité l'hydrogène
quand sa production et du carbone et
sans souci là dessus mais arrêtons le
fantasme de l'eau lien c'est terminé
stéphanie von euw oui moi je pense qu'il
faudrait vraiment être sérieux dans ce
débat et que le mandat khiari c'est le
mandat du climat donc déjà la meilleure
énergie c'est celle qu'on ne dépense pas
c'est pourquoi déjà la priorité absolue
c'est un grand plan de rénovation
thermique vraiment très efficace pour
lutter contre les gaz à effet de serre
lutter aussi contre la précarité
énergétique qui gagne de plus en plus de
nos concitoyens dans notre région et
c'est très bon pour l'emploi local
après se pose effectivement le mix
énergétique dans lequel l'éolien à sa
place l'éolien effectivement il faut la
plante et pas n'importe où c'est pas des
fonds d'investissement qui doit être à
la manoeuvre
mais effectivement beaucoup plus de
citoyens de collectivités locales et
territoriales qui doit son nom
n'apparaît pas forcément un essai qui
sont des landes c'est qu'ils sont
démentes et c'est bien pour ça que je
suis bien pour ça que je ne veux pas de
contention effectué le grand jeu de
société sont citoyens il ya de l'argent
qui a été épargné la proposons aux
citoyens d'investir dans une énergie
locale non délocalisables pour le coup
qui ne soit pas le nucléaire le
nucléaire actuellement
effectivement les centrales sont en fin
de vie il ya de nombreuses centrales
conte de proust sérieux problèmes de
fonctionnement
le père dont on nous vante les mérites
c'était 3 milliards d'euros démarrage
maintenant 1 à 20 milliards d'euros
on nous dit qu'on veut en construire six
autres c'est n'importe quoi avec cet
argent en faisant autre chose faisons
autre chose notamment aussi donc nous
pour les transports en commun encore une
fois parce que les ter c'est notre
compétence et que par ce biais là nous
avons aussi des économies à faire en
termes de gaz à effet de serre et c'est
aussi aider
pour les voix être pour lier pour
notamment les personnes pour le
transport du quotidien qui viennent
travailler qui viennent faire leurs
études de leur proposer des tarifs
attractifs et puisse effectivement tout
ce qui tourne autour de la biodiversité
ça a été évoqué tout à l'heure la forêt
enjeu majeur un tiers de notre
territoire une forêt en très mauvais
état
il faut donc investir vraiment sur la
biodiversité dans notre région pour
pouvoir effectivement sauvegarder notre
climat et notre planète et en même temps
les bruines franche comté